[Musique]
au lendemain de cette épidémie due
coronavirus parce qu'on voit à peu près
les conséquences économiques
on va être un peu fixé mais les
conséquences politiques en interne elles
sont pas neutres
alors d'abord sur la l'épidémie la chine
c'est une vingtaine de régions qui
fonctionnent comme des pays européens en
fait et l'état central coordonne les
régions et la complexité de la direction
des régions actuellement en chine c'est
que les responsables du parti communiste
de chaque région sont en fait noté sur
leurs résultats dans la dans la région
sur la base des données qu'ils envoient
eux-mêmes à à pékin où il ya des
présidents il a durci énormément
l'organisation et est donc c'est comme
des élèves qui souhaiteraient eux mêmes
pour les examens donc dans le cas de
l'épidémie à one
les responsables locaux n'ont pas voulu
on essayait d'étouffer la faire pour de
l'épidémie au mois de décembre puisqu'à
mi décembre ont commencé à avoir
suffisamment d'informations pour agir
ils ont caché la nature de l'épidémie et
quand le pouvoir central a pris
conscience deux semaines après de ce qui
se passait et des répercussions sur
l'ensemble de la chine à ce moment-là à
xi jinping qui avait déjà terriblement
dur si le rayer le fonctionnement du
régime depuis son arrivée en 2013 à
donner un nouveau tour de vis
extrêmement fort et donc la question
politique que vous posez est là devant
nous pour deux à trois années c'est à
dire que la question c'est comment vont
se rétablir de nouveaux équilibres à
l'intérieur du parti communiste et les
relations entre les régions et le
pouvoir central
[Musique]